hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a level 65 candy crush soda saga
walkthrough this one is a little bit
confusing when you first get to it
because you have to bring the bears down
first and then bring them back up and
there's a couple of trapped in the
bottom so make sure you look at our
guide when we explain that a little bit
better the I think it made it a little
bit bit easier that it used to be but
it's still confusing you can't figure
out when it's going up and down so what
you want to do is you want to try to hit
these cakes at the bottom because when
you drop this you see that the board
Scrolls back up so we need to pop the
bottles to get him across and we can do
that it's a green bottle so we can use
this color bomb up here hit the green
and then that'll pop that bottle you
might think that's a big waste of the
color bomb but it's not at all because
that's really our main priority right
now is popping those bottles and get to
the top
in fact specials aren't as important
here as they are in a lot of other
levels because the board Scrolls so much
so anything that will get you up to the
top as quick as possible and you want to
set up stripes like this are really good
because I'll clear out the whole row and
send the bear up so here's here's what I
was talking about earlier you see how
these cakes are pulling the Bears at the
bottom - you can get them up one side at
a time because the board's gonna scroll
again but just you see how I hit the
ones on the Left first so that I can get
through them faster next time if you can
bring them all up at the same time
that's great - but the bottles you know
the the board's already filled with soda
so now we're just we'll get these two to
the string then I'm gonna scroll us back
down
and then we'll be able to bring the
other two up fish
there's no cakes or anything on the
board so fish will kind of always hit a
candy that's in front of your bear so
fish can be good like that one was fish
plus the stripes will be even better
because it'll clear out that whole row
and here we can just use this other blue
fish to get that one out of the way and
now we'll bring out the other two we
have 19 moves left so that that should
be plenty shouldn't be that complicated
really but you just pay attention to how
it Scrolls basically the the bear the
Bears or the one bear are the are the
are the center of focus so wherever it's
at the board adjusts to keep it sort of
in the middle so it'll go up and down if
you're not moving forward so just keep
that in mind and then just you know
trying to make your fish so that you can
like here we can make two fish match
them together and that'll finish things
up for us with nine moves left so you
might have to leave your wine the video
a little bit look at it and definitely
look at the tips on our guide for more
info on it but real quick just you know
you want to hit hit the cakes at the
bottom when you can before popping the
bottles if possible to make that part
easier and then just plants that trying
things out so that you can get up
quickly without wasting moves I hope
this helps please subscribe to our
channel make sure you like the video and
check us out soon because we add more
videos like this all the time thanks